CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AND THEY FEEL
LIKE IT IS IMPORTANT TO PUT
THAT FORWARD TO THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE.
SARAH MURRAY, CNN, WASHINGTON.
WE >> WILL NEED A LAST-MINUTE
CHRISTMAS PRESENT?
HOW IS THIS FOR A STOCKING
STUFFER.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
HAS RULED OUT NFT DIGITAL
TRADING CARDS AT THE BARGAIN
PRICE OF $99.
NOW YOU CAN GET THAT SPECIAL
SOMEONE IN YOUR LIFE DIGITAL
ARCH OF TRUMP AS A SUPERHERO,
COMPLETE WITH YES, PHOTOSHOPPED
MUSCLES.
OR TRUMP AS AN ASTRONAUT,
BOXING CHAMPION, OR
PROFESSIONAL GOLFER.
TRUMP BUILD THE DEBUT OF THE
CARD IS A MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
LET YOU BE THE JUDGE.
CNN'S JOHN SYLLABLE JOINS ME.
NOW JOHN, THIS DOES SEEM TO BE
ANYTHING MORE THAN TRUMP TRYING
TO MAKE A QUICK BUCK?
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS
ASTOUNDING TO SOME OF OUR
VIEWERS.
AND IS IT WORKING?
WE >> WELL, IT IS WORKING RIGHT
NOW.
THIS PROJECT HAS SOLD OUT.
IT IS SELLING AT RIGHT NOW
AROUND FIVE TIMES THE 99 DOLLAR
PRICE.
SO, A LOT OF MONEY IS COMING
IN.
YOU CAN GO INTO OPENS SCENE
WHICH IS THE BIG AND UP TO THE
MARKETPLACE AND SEE TRUMP'S
COLLECTION RIGHT UP ON THE TOP.
FOR ANYONE WHO HAS FOLLOWED
CRYPTO, AND SPECIFICALLY THIS
CRYPTO CELEBRITY INDUSTRY, IT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A BIT OF THE
TRUMP HIMSELF HASN'T GOTTEN IN
EARLIER.
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT
REWARDS CELEBRITIES WITH A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF SHAMELESSNESS
WHO ARE WILLING TO HAWK THESE,
ESSENTIALLY WORTHLESS PROJECTS
ON TO THEIR FANS.
WELL, ANYONE WHO HAS A CURSORY
KNOWLEDGE OF TRUMP'S BUSINESS
DEALINGS KNOWS THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HE WOULD
PROBABLY BE INTERESTED IN.
THIS IS LIKE TRUMP STAKES
WITHOUT THE ME.
AND, WHEN YOU SEE TRUMP GET
INVOLVED IN THE CRYPTO MARKET,
IT IS COMING OUT A VERY
INTERESTING TIME IN CRYPTO.
THE PRICES OF CRYPTO HAVE
FALLEN, AS WE ARE SEEING FTX
AND FTX'S FORMER CEO GET
INDICTED.
AND THOSE NAMES DELAYED
CELEBRITIES WHO WERE ENDORSED
ENCRYPT OR NOW FIGHTING
THEMSELVES ON THE WRONG END OF
CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS.
SO, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE
THIS GRAND ENTRANCE INTO THE
CRYPTO MARKET AT A VERY
INTERESTING TIME.
AND IT IS COMING WITH A COST.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS
LITERALLY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
AND HE SEES DID WITH, AS YOU,
SAID WITH HIS MAJOR
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHEN THAT MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT
TURNED OUT TO BE THIS ENOUGH T
COLLECTION, SOME OF HIS CLOSEST
ALLIES SAW IT AS BENEATH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND LASHED
OUT.
PEOPLE LIKE MICHAEL FLYNN, AND
STEVE BANNON.
WE >> I CAN DO THIS ANYMORE.
WE HE'S ONE OF THE GREATEST
PRESIDENTS IN HISTORY, BUT I
GOTTA TELL YOU, WHATEVER
BUSINESS PARTNER, ANYBODY IN
THE COMPS TEAM IN MAR-A-LAGO,
AND LOVE THE FOLKS DOWN THERE.
BUT WE ARE AT WAR.
THEY OUGHT TO BE FIRED TODAY.
YOU CAME OUT WITH SOMETHING
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT, WHICH I
STILL DON'T THINK GETS TO THE
HEART OF IT, AND TAKE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THREE HARVARD
COURTS AND CORTEZ BANNON AND --
WE.
>> SO, YEAH TRUMP IS SELLING
THESE ENTITIES RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY TRADING FOR
MORE THAN PEOPLE INITIALLY PAID
FOR.
BUT THE QUESTION IS, FOR TRUMP,
AT WHAT COST?
>> WE YEAH.
IT IS SOMETHING WHEN THE
FANBOYS ARE BOUND.
AS STEVE BANNON WAS JUST
INDICATING.
AND, THIS JUST IN.
SOMETIMES TRUMP'S CLAIMS ARE
NOT WHAT THEY CRACKED UP TO BE.
WHO KNEW.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, JOHN.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE GLASS OF
FTX.
YOU MENTIONED, THE FOUNDER WAS
INDICTED THIS WEEKEND EIGHT
CRIMINAL CHARGES INCLUDING
FRAUD IN CONSPIRACY.
WE SHOULD KNOW THIS COMPANY WAS
ENDORSED BY MULTIPLE
CELEBRITIES, INCLUDING TOM
BRADY, STEPH CURRY.
ONE CELEBRITY FORMER OC STAR
BEN MCKENZIE SLAMMED CRYPTO IN
A SENATE HEARING THIS WEEK.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE DEMISE OF FTX AND.
REPRESENT THE MOST SPECTACULAR
CORPORATE DOWNFALL SINCE BERNIE
MADOFF PONZI SCHEME IMPLODED IN
THE WAKE OF THE GREAT FINANCIAL
CRISIS.
IN MY OPINION, THE
CRYPTOCURRENCY INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS THE LARGEST PONZI
SCHEME IN HISTORY.
IN FACT, BY THE TIME THE DUST
SETTLES, CRYPTO MAY WHERE
PRESENT A FRAUD, AT LEAST TEN
TIMES BIGGER THAN MADE ALL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, JOHN?
IS CRYPTO HEADING TO THE CRYPT,?
MATT >> WELL, THE FALL OF FTX
HAD A TREMENDOUSLY NEGATIVE
EFFECT ON THE CRYPTO MARKET.
BITCOIN IS STILL SELLING FOR
MANY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS BUT,
THIS SENSE OF INEVITABILITY
THAT PEOPLE IN THE CRYPTO
INDUSTRY PROJECTED, THAT THIS
WAS THE FUTURE OF FINANCE, THAT
IT WOULD REPLACE FIAT, THOSE
PROSPECTS WERE ALWAYS A LITTLE
PIE IN THE SKY, NOW SEEM FAIRLY
RIDICULOUS.
BUT, AS THIS TRUMP NFC
COLLECTION SHOWS THAT WHEN
PRICES START TO GO UP, THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE PEOPLE WILLING
TO GAMBLE THAT THEY ARE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE BUBBLE.
>> WE KNOW JURORS HAVE BEEN
SPOKEN.
THAT MIGHT ALSO BE THE
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE YEAR IN